okay great thank you so today I'm going
to talk about some patient studies and
I'm going to focus initially on what we
think about internal models or what we
could call internal models in cerebellar
dysfunction and I'm gonna move ahead and
talk about some other studies of
learning that are based on these
observations that ultimately help us to
sort of use mechanisms that we think are
important in the cerebellum to help with
other kinds of patients so my work is
I'm gonna talk to you about studies that
sort of loop back on to themselves when
I when I started my work many years ago
I was really interested in people who
have cerebellar ataxia and I'm gonna
show you what that looks like because
we've been talking about the cerebellum
and how it contributes to movement
control and from my perspective I'm very
interested in helping these people to
learn how to move better and this is a
very challenging problem and so in
understanding their deficits I wanted to
know whether I could understand how
their learning problems would relate to
movement function and we studied
cerebellar motor learning across many
different domains which ultimately led
us to study normal motor learning I'm
gonna talk today about some look of
motor learning as well and eventually
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you some data
that understanding this process actually
helps us to rehabilitate people with
some very serious cerebral lesions and
this has actually a very fruitful
process with my Google Drive
and and my duck hmm sorry where did it
go I can't see without my glasses okay
thank you so so okay so studying this
process has actually been essential to
understanding how to leverage these
mechanisms for rehabilitating people
with cerebral lesions now the problem is
I actually haven't done a very good job
of understanding these mechanisms well
enough to help people with cerebellar
damage so that's why this circle loops
back down onto itself because right now
we're really focusing on other learning
mechanisms to try to understand how to
deal with people with cerebellar ataxia
so what I'm gonna do to start with us
show you what somebody with cerebellar
ataxia look like looks like this is a
gentleman that has a sporadic condition
he has a degenerative disease in the
cerebellum and he shows fairly pure
cerebellar signs he's gonna reach to his
chin and to my finger and what you see
is he oscillate he misses the target and
has to make corrections
you'll also notice his trunk tends to
move as he moves his arm so he's not
stabilizing his body for the dynamics of
his arm movements this is a very classic
looking reaching dysmetria and
cerebellar disease and so we've been
interested in this for many years and
trying to understand what is going wrong
in these patients now when you see these
guys they can move they can create force
they look they're not weak they're not
paralyzed in any way yet the movements
that they make are this classic in
coordinated dissymmetric movement and so
we recently decided to see if we could
understand if there is a problem of
model dynamics in the brain and if there
is which has been speculated over many
years is it something that we can
actually change and so the question
really is is the brains model dynamics
different than the actual dynamics and
if it is can we do something about it so
we study people that have degenerative
diseases in this case so here you can
see the cerebellum in this MRI and you
can see this playing of the folia so
this is somebody who has a very
significant cerebellar degeneration and
what we did with these folks is we had
them make reaching movements and really
simple reaching movements in this case
so we put them into a robot this is a
kid arm robot and we had them make some
single jointed rapid reaching movements
now in doing this this allowed us to
identify whether we could see a bias in
their internal representation of their
bodies inertia and their body's
viscosity so just for to give people a
real feel of what these properties are
of course inertia is the predominant
thing that you feel when you swing a
baseball bat and you have to decelerate
it so your limbs are very inertial
viscosity of course if you're stirring
honey or moving through water you feel
velocity-dependent force so this is
acceleration dependent and this is
velocity dependent so the task looks
like this people are seated in a chair
this is a bird's-eye view of somebody at
a start target and we asked them to make
a rapid elbow movement to a stop target
it's about a thirty degree movement and
what you can see here are just some
examples subjects that are making these
movements here's a typical control and
what you're seeing is the start to the
stop thirty degrees is where where the
this person was able to stop and the
heatmap
indicated indicates whether they over or
under shot the target as you can see
this person as we would expect is moving
rapidly and is able to stop right on the
money now the interesting thing in this
study that actually surprised me until I
went back and did some more reading is
that we had people that showed hyper
metria over shooting and they showed
hyper metria every time they came back
into the lab this pattern was their
pattern it was idiosyncratic to the
patient and we had patients that showed
hypo metria that is they under shot the
target and this was idiosyncratic to
their reaching behavior and again
bringing people in over and over again
we saw these patterns of movement now
the other thing that was interesting to
us that was important in identifying the
problems that they had is the fact that
the hyper metric people tended to move
too slow at the beginning of their
movement their velocities were low but
by the end of the movement when feedback
kicks in they start to speed up and they
overshoot the target and you see the
opposite pattern in the hypo metric
patients they start out actually moving
too fast and then feedback based
Corrections make them slow down and they
understood the target now this is
interesting to us because it allowed us
to make some two makes to speculate
about what kind of mismatch we're seeing
in the internal model dynamics versus
the actual body and so what we did to
try to identify this are three things
the first thing we did is we look to see
if we could induce the same kinds of
problems in healthy people so this is a
plot showing again the position of the
elbow plotted as a function of time and
what we've done is we've increased and
decreased the inertia of the limb or
we've increased and decreased the
viscosity of the limb and what you can
see is if you take a healthy
let them reach a lot and occasionally
you give them this perturbation you get
these very stereotyped responses again
with changes in the early velocity and
over-and-under shooting now you can also
do this in a model a very simple model
where we're modeling a mismatch between
internal model dynamics that are in the
controller and the plant and the model
reproduces what we see nicely in the
control perturbations and so we can we
can reproduce something that could look
cerebellar like in these two situations
now the interesting thing is that if you
take these the the model and the control
perturbations it's only in the inertial
perturbations that we see the same
pattern of early velocity and
overshooting so the inertial
perturbations looked the most like our
patients so we took this information and
we went back to our patient data and we
fit the model to our our patients in a
patient specific way so here we had a
hyper metric patient we fit the model to
a portion of their data and look to see
how well the model explained it we did
the same thing with hypo metric patients
and what you're seeing here again is the
model in the green dotted line and the
behavior in the in the orange line so we
could fit their data pretty well
actually and it was it was actually the
best fits we got were with only the
inertial inertial term inertia and
viscosity when you let it play out it
doesn't look like their pattern of
overshooting and then correction at the
end of the movement now to us this was
actually nice because we could make a
prediction now we have a model that says
your plant doesn't match your internal
dynamics in this way by this much
inertia and because we have this robot
we can add and subtract inertia within
certain ranges as we like and so what we
did is we said patient by patient we
figured out their mismatch and then we
added or subtracted inertia in the way
that we thought would help them so what
you see here are our patients this is
the amount of dis metria or overshooting
that you see this is an individual
patient here and this is before and
after we added the
the appropriate inertia or subtractive
the appropriate inertia and what you can
see is that if we give patient-specific
compensations we can move them closer to
zero error and we also correct their
initial velocity problem now what you'll
also notice is that these guys are
really variable so each subject has a
lot of interest subject variability the
standard deviation bars here are quite
large of course between subjects we get
nice responses in the right direction
but we haven't corrected their
variability so this is only part of this
problem that these patients have but
wait what we have identified is a
patient specific bias in these internal
representations and we can replicate it
both with control subjects in using a
very simple model and we can actually
correct it on a patient by patient basis
with the robot so this is proof of
principle that we can identify something
that looks like an internal model
mismatch between the plant and the
brains model dynamics now at this point
it's a it's very much a toy problem so
we're only looking at this very simple
movement in the robot and in the real
world what what we want to be able to do
is to change their representation or to
be able to deal with their
misrepresentation of their entire body
and we haven't started doing that yet
the other thing is that they're not
learning anything here we're just
correcting it for them and so we're all
Tamiya interested in understanding how
to leverage other systems to help them
to learn and I'm not sure that we're
going to be able to do that and so
that's one of the things that we're
exploring right now so I'm gonna move on
and I'm gonna talk a little bit now
about cerebellar deficits and motor
learning so all of us here change body
dynamics with age we change weight in
good directions and bad directions we
have deal with lots of objects that are
inertial and so we have to constantly be
recalibrating this internal
representation of body dynamics and we
know from the other talks today that
these are error driven learning
mechanisms to predictable demands and
they persist and when you remove the
predictable demand so you have to watch
them out so we and actually this is a
study that was done with you
and urine had a huge huge part in this
study he he really did a lot of the work
with my student now and Singh
what we did is we asked the question
what kind of error is really most
salient for this kind of learning
process this cerebellum error dependent
learning and by that I mean is it
important if we let people make motor
Corrections for their error or is it
only important that they actually see
their error and they don't make a motor
correction so in this case we had people
reaching two three targets and we
introduced a visual rotation which I'm
not going to describe again because
you've just heard about that part way
through this paradigm and then we look
to see how people learn that recheck
that of that rotation now the
interesting thing here is that in one
condition we ask people to correct and
to get right on the target so they were
allowed to reach and make corrections
and move to the target and in another
condition we had them shoot through the
target we didn't let them make
corrections we had to move quickly and
go right past the target now
one idea that we had initially was if
you're a healthy person and I give you a
mile ow to make motor Corrections you
might learn better because you have an
extra source of information about your
error you now have the motor corrections
that you can use if you're a cerebellar
patient your corrections are irregular
and they tend to be extensive and it
might actually worsen your learning and
so we were wondering whether these
Corrections would have different effects
on controls and people with cerebellar
damage and so what we found is that they
didn't in fact if you have people point
here is a control here reach
trajectories from a bird's eye view
here's a cerebellar patient you can see
they have this this interesting pattern
of dis metria and it's due to the
anisotropy of the arm big errors in
certain directions you introduce the
rotation you can see it here blue to
green there's our rotation and early
learning late learning the controls look
good there orange is right over there
baseline whereas the patients continue
to not learn then when we go to post
learning and we remove the perturbation
these guys have
aftereffects in the opposite direction
and these guys pretty much go back to
their regular regular pattern so we
didn't really I'll tell you we did not
make these people worse with their motor
Corrections and we didn't make these
people better if you do the same
experiment with the shooting movements
controls are perturbed they learn and
they show after-effects cerebellar
patients are perturbed they don't learn
and they don't have After Effects so
it's interesting that this sensory error
is really all that's operational here in
this learning paradigm the motor
Corrections didn't seem to matter very
much and we were we were I was a little
bit surprised by this I was expecting
motor Corrections to be meaningful here
but they were not so I'm gonna turn my
attention now to walking because again
my goals in the lab are really at
understanding these mechanisms well
enough to help people with their
rehabilitation and walking is sort of
the number one thing that people come in
and really want to be able to do so over
the years we've developed a paradigm
that really was was based on work in cat
and some work in in infants and some
work in adults by Dietz using a split
belt treadmill and so wouldn't you walk
on a regular treadmill of course you can
make predictions about what one leg
should do based on the sensory
information you're getting from the
other leg because both of the treadmill
belts are moving at the same speed in
this case we're going to be looking at
people moving with the belts decoupled
so one leg will be moving at a different
speed than the other leg so what I'm
going to show you here is this is just
an animation of somebody walking on a
treadmill and as they're doing this
we're constantly monitoring the
three-dimensional position of their legs
in their trunk and we're gonna be making
some measurements one of the
measurements that we'll make a lot is
the step length difference so how big
their step is when their right foot is
forward and how big their step is when
their left foot is forward we'll also
then be splitting the belts so here's a
bird's eye view you can see that we have
independent control of these two belts
and I'm gonna be manipulating that in
the paradigm so this is actually a fun
paradigm for a few reasons and I think a
I think it's a cool paradigm for a few
reasons one is
I put you on this treadmill and you
don't have to think about anything you
learn it you do not have to in fact you
can't tell me what it is that you're
doing it's it's it's very hard to
articulate what you're doing as you're
learning which means that we can study
really really young kids we can study
people that don't pay attention very
well we can do all kinds of things the
paradigm that we use is very simple we
start out with the belts tied at
baseline then we split the belts during
learning and in this case it's a three
to one split and then we go back to tied
belts to look to see the effects of this
learning process so now I'll show you
some balloon guys that we animate from
the data because everybody likes balloon
guys and what I'm gonna show you is this
is baseline tied belt walking down here
you can see the alternating pattern of
the two legs so the legs is they're
moving forward and backwards and what
you'll notice is that they're in
anti-phase
and they're oscillating around the same
midpoint so the people are walking with
their legs underneath them here what I'm
gonna do is show you what happens when I
first introduce a three to one
perturbation now with the three-to-one
perturbation I'll tell you straight up
you don't take three steps and then one
step you maintain alternation and in
fact you never take three steps in one
step it's hard to make yourself do that
but what you do is this you limp so the
blue leg is on the fast belt the yellow
leg is on the slow belt and what you can
see is that the legs are taking
different size steps big steps small
step big step small step and you've
introduced a disruption in phase and
you've also introduced a change in the
point about which the legs are
oscillating when leg is actually walking
in front of the other leg and so this
pattern you could do this all day but
you don't you actually correct this you
can see the step sizes become the same
and the alternation is in phase in
anti-phase again and you're also lating
around the same midpoint so this is the
learning that you do during this task
and if we go back to this condition what
happens is you actually have after
effects that are in the opposite
direction so little step biggest
little step big step so you have a
change in the center of oscillation
about your body and again you have this
phase disruption and all of those things
lead to a problem 'try issue during
learning and post learning okay so this
is the basic paradigm gonna tell you a
lot about this now in sort of snippets
the first thing I'm going to tell you is
you're gonna see graphs that look like
this
so we analyzed thousands and thousands
of steps and what you see here is a
measure that I'll call step symmetry
it's the difference between the step
sizes normalized to their sum we
normalize it to their son because Tempe
some people are tall and take big steps
and some people are shorter and take
small steps so that way we can make a
fair comparison so here is baseline
people walk it symmetry we split the
bells people learn over a couple of
hundred steps here is a little catch
trial where we put the belts back to
symmetry and then you relearn a little
bit and then here's the after effect
when we go to tied belts so this is step
symmetry as a function of step number
okay so the first thing I'll tell you
which I'm sure you you would predict
based on what you've seen so far is that
if you're updating some kind of internal
representation of your movement on this
weird device it's cerebellum dependent
so here's a cerebellar patient walking
on our treadmill we put lots of old and
impaired people on this thing and they
do pretty well they can maintain a
stepping pattern they can produce pretty
good anti-phase but as soon as we
introduce a two-to-one perturbation in
this case the pink leg is going faster
than the blue you can see that they limp
and they continue to limp in fact they
get kind of tired and they don't they
don't learn and we've put people on this
for for long periods of time and we've
been unable to get them to learn this
new pattern so you go back to regular
treadmill walking and it looks very much
like baseline so this is just another
example of the many that you've already
seen showing that this this kind of
error dependent learning process we
think is is cerebellum dependent and
here is
the split belt walking each dot is a
step symmetry value they just don't
learn and they don't have any
after-effects now okay so all I've shown
you in this section is that we know
something about cerebellum dependent
learning mechanisms we know that they
occur in reaching and walking we also
know they occur in the oculomotor system
and postural control and we know that
you don't necessarily have to make motor
Corrections in order to be able to learn
from sensory errors and that in fact it
really doesn't seem to make a difference
in the reaching movements I've told you
about so I'm gonna turn now because
we've been studying this in the
cerebellum and we're very interested in
updating internal representations of
movement but we don't it's it's a little
bit hard to think about what exactly is
being learned in this case people can't
articulate it and we can measure things
but the question is what what is really
going on
the first thing that I'll say is
honestly you don't really have to learn
this you could walk like this and get
where you're going and in fact I'll show
you that stroke patients do just that
but but healthy folks adults and
children do learn this pattern and what
it seems that they're learning is can be
can be represented in two domains so
what I'm showing you here is another
representation just like those limb
angles so this is this is flexion
extension flexion extension this is the
leg that's going fast on the treadmill
this is the leg that's going slow on the
treadmill zero here is sort of midline
of your body so you can see this leg the
the solid line leg is walking in front
of the body a little bit and the back
leg is walking behind and at the brake
you can go do that and you can do it
pretty well can stop very hard even
though it seems weird so what you see
here is the spread of the legs that can
be represented as sort of this distance
between these two angles so it's sort of
the spread of the legs in this case the
slow step is a lot bigger because the
fast leg is yanked behind and the fast
step is a lot smaller and this is the
asymmetry that we've been measuring all
along now one way to look at this is to
say well how would you
correct this problem if your legs are
ones walking in front of the other one
and they're not in good anti-phase you
can correct it in two ways one way you
could do it is you could shift in space
realign the point about which your legs
are oscillating and when you do that you
actually equalize the step sizes so all
I've done here is you see that the
oscillation point has been shifted down
so that the legs are taking even steps
the other thing you can do is you could
shift these two curves in time relative
to one another so you could change the
phase and when you do that you can also
change the stepping symmetry by simply
changing the phasing between the two
legs now I tell you this because we
think that these are probably
independently controlled we think that
this one may be more spinal and this one
may be more set as well cerebellar but
I'll show you some data and you can you
can decide for yourself the first thing
I'll show you is that these things
develop at different times so what I'm
showing you here is our measure of step
symmetry and this is adaptation and post
adaptation this is step count and this
is the perturbation in adults so it
looks very double exponential nice
learning curves very tight this is what
it looks like in children here we have
aged 3 to 5 6 to 8 9 to 11 12 to 14 and
so forth what I want you to notice is
that this kind of learning is not mature
in 3 to 5 6 to 8 even 9 to 11 year-olds
don't show this nice double exponential
pattern of learning they learn slower
and they learn more in a single
exponential or linear way so learning of
this walking pattern isn't really mature
until you get closer to 12 which is a
little bit surprising because we think
of walking as being mature around age 6
yet now if we break apart this step
symmetry measure and I say where is this
learning problem coming from it turns
out that it's the spatial component of
learning that is disrupted in these
children that is not mature so here
actually are
to eight-year-olds are our youngest kids
kind of show flat learning in this case
these guys show very slow learning as do
the nine to eleven year olds and you
really only start to see an adult-like
pattern later in contrast if you look at
the temporal measure the phasing look at
the little kids I mean these guys have
even though they're more variable they
have a nice double exponential pattern
of learning and it's all the way through
development you see that this has not
changed
so we seem to see a preferential
developmental time course for learning
this spatial control the other thing
I'll quickly tell you is that if you
stimulate the cerebellum in healthy
adults you can actually using
transcranial direct current stimulation
you can speed up the learning by putting
the anode over it and you can slow down
the learning by putting a cathode over
the cerebellum which initially I thought
this is crazy this isn't gonna work at
all but this kind of non-invasive brain
stimulation can actually modulate
learning rate and it turns out the way
it does this is again through our
spatial control not through the temporal
control so here you can see we speed up
spatial control with a nodal stimulation
and we slow it down with cathodal
stimulation and here we don't change the
phase so the point here is that we've
got this kind of learning we can break
it apart and we can actually show that
there seem to be two systems involved in
this learning and one is very automatic
and obligatory and it comes online
really early in childhood the other one
seems to develop in childhood and is
amenable to stimulation to the
cerebellum we can manipulate it okay in
the remaining few minutes I'll just tell
you one more thing because really what I
my laboratory is interested in is taking
taking this - translation so we want to
make people like this walk better this
is somebody who's had a cerebral stroke
and you can see that they limp
so all I've shown you up until now is is
healthy people and how I can train in a
limp so this is somebody who's had a
stroke and what I'd like to do is train
out their limp
so it turns out that we have a lot of
data on people with cerebral lesions we
know that people with cerebellar damage
don't adapt adults and children with
cerebral damage do adapt they can
transfer their learning nicely to over
ground walking and I'll show you they
can improve with long term training so
the hypothesis that we've been pursuing
is that can we use this system to
correct for deficits that we see from
damage to the other system and so it
turns out that this is at first it was
kind of an a non intuitive thing to do
but it turns out that we can actually
take people and we can force them to
learn any walking pattern again without
them having to think about taking a big
step or a small step by putting them on
this treadmill so this is somebody who
suffered a stroke here I'm showing you
what their step lengths were like as
they're walking along on the treadmill
and this is with the treadmill belts
tied and that means this person has a
limp they're taking a longer step with
their non paretic leg actually so they
don't like to stand on their bad leg
they're pyretic leg and so I'm sorry I
said that backwards they can't advance
their paretic leg this this asymmetry
gets bigger when they walk fast or stand
then smaller when they walk slow what we
found is that if we split the belts and
we make their asymmetry worse that
forces them to learn how to correct it
so when we go back to the regular
treadmill if you compare blue to yellow
what you can see is that we force them
into a more symmetric walking pattern
I'll tell you straight up if you ask a
stroke patient if you say please you
know try to take an even step try to
take an even step what they'll do is
they'll take a smaller step with one of
their legs to try to even it out it's
actually very hard to get them to do
something like this and they've kind of
met in the middle here but the point is
is that we're trying to leverage
cerebellum dependent mechanisms in order
to help them to acquire a new walking
pattern this is just to give you another
video this is actually our most severe
cerebral lesion this is somebody who's
had a hemispherectomy
so this is a little girl this is three
weeks after her hemispherectomy which
she had for seizure disorders she had
she has rasmussen encephalopathy and
so they took out this is actually her
brain they took out one hemisphere
they don't disrupt the ventricle they
don't get rid of the thalamus if they
can and this is gonna be her walking on
my treadmill here she is a baseline and
what I want to show you is her asymmetry
she has trouble swinging her bad leg
through which is the leg farthest away
from you and so she takes asymmetric
steps she's not able to get that leg
into nice extension so that's what
you're seeing here then we put her on
the split belt and we actually
exaggerate her limp to try to force the
nervous system to learn a new pattern
and so this is a bit harder for her
she's still vaulting on her toe to try
to get her leg through but we trained
her like this for 10 minutes and after
10 minutes we can get her to do
something that looks like this so we've
got symmetry back she's not bolting on
her leg and she's able to pull this leg
into nice extension and that's really
what we want her to do so this is a
purely therapeutic application now 10
minutes not gonna change her game
pattern 10 minutes it's gonna wash back
out but what we found is that repeated
exposures to this can actually train
people to learn any walking pattern and
it's probably not just through the
cerebellum dependent mechanism it's
probably through cerebellum dependent
mechanisms with some kind of
reinforcement learning on top of it
I'll show you what this kid looks like a
few years later I saw her at a I saw her
at a hemispheric tree reunion and I
videoed her walking you can see I don't
do good correction mark anyhow look at I
mean this walking is amazing you can
also see she never got her hand back
which is pretty typical for this the
hand never never returns so this is kind
of a neat application which wasn't what
we are going for at the beginning we are
going for correcting cerebellum
dependent movement problems this slide
is just to show that we can train a
group of stroke survivors at baseline
their asymmetric post for weeks they're
more symmetric but they're not perfect
and then but then they keep they keep
improving even when they leave our
training program and they're getting
even better so we think this
is a useful application of understanding
something about how these how these
systems work together okay so what I've
shown you here is that you know it's
nice that understanding this kind of
learning well enough it allows us to to
apply it to something that that may be
useful for patients and we're still
studying this long term learning and
we're trying to understand who will
benefit and who won't
because usually not everybody benefits
and what's interesting is we're finding
that if we put the really severe stroke
survivors on our treadmill and these are
the people that take it like a step and
then they pause and they take another
step and they pause they don't learn
very well at all you really have to be
walking to learn on this treadmill and
if you walk too slowly it doesn't seem
to help very much but if you walk at a
decent speed like I mean it could still
be a very slow speed they learn really
well okay so that was that was sort of
that's sort of the loop that we went
through as I mentioned before I haven't
done very well in that regard now I know
a little bit more about about maybe
there's this mismatch in their internal
representation of limb dynamics we're
pursuing other learning mechanisms in
the cerebellar patients so right now
we've been studying some reinforcement
learning giving binary feedback and
letting people explore and we've got
some interesting results we're working
on a paper on that right now comparing
it to error based learning and and
Daniel will produce been helping us with
the modeling of that we're also applying
other learning mechanisms layering them
on top of the adaptive learning
mechanisms to try to improve sort of the
stickiness of the learning and the
stroke patients so it's it's it's one of
many things but I think that this this
knowledge of internal representations is
actually really useful and I always like
seeing all of the data from from the
lower animals because it's really
helpful to me to think about what's
possible so all in good thank you